okay Fernando madam yeah
recent French games let's to win so
let's just do it again come on play the
French you know that that's a very very
comfortable line yeah he's playing
rather quickly just like if it's the
most normal line ever which is really
isn't why it has given up his best piece
the the bishop on d3 and I've already
rather comfortable here let's see okay I
can try to trade with the Bishop to b5
which is not bad a5 is also interesting
it's both both very very feasible not
sure what's better in any case I'm okay
here this is maybe the more passive way
to play
a passive is the wrong word but kind of
conservative maybe I don't know
yeah I'm not going to trade this okay
but is this any good
I mean if five or what are you good
going to do after if five okay and I'm
going to I'm going to flick this in so
night p5 is also not clear to me what
what's movers going back off what are
you doing
we've five
Jake Bishop takes rook big one maybe I
don't know this is not bad and Siwon is
hanging he cannot take on b5 and this I
can take a three yeah this should be
fired
hello kind of a weird game so I just won
upon four basically very little or let's
say nothing
the only thing is it's still a little
bit crammed to this position I would
like to get in v6 under favorable
circumstances mmm any way to do that I
can also just take I mean it's not bad
maybe not the best way to play no but I
mean it's clearly Bishop takes if I was
not the best move so let's not do it
okay
briefly thinking quick xv5 or some kind
of move but it's not going to work
probably not at least not easy to play
them okay it's trying to to do something
on the sorry on the kingside okay it's
wrecking is structure even more so b6
was the the whole point of this this big
operation
night a six I can do various things take
before the or Quincy for Quincy for was
the main idea yeah this is just just
miss placing the night totally 93 was
the point for 94 and asking him really
what is your night doing one a six
b5 see can can you play b5 maybe and saw
the whole loan that's still rubbish
position but it's but anyway he has to
probably do that
and this g4 g5 has also weakened White's
King side so I cannot enter them here
just some small moves f3 I've got 93
okay so let's enter it should be quite
good yeah if you attack basically with
this ninety 90 out of the game but how
exactly is it is it winning ship Bishop
h4 might be good trading the defender
okay come on come on always a bit of a
debatable choice because this Bishop is
so bad but I want I want him some
substantial progress and I'm think I'm
getting it and that this way threat is
to take and Queen age 1 just for getting
from getting through King side attack
while taking in just winning defaults
also what's impossible I'm warning Queen
B to write for for the deadly pin Queen
F 193 wins the Queen
that's no way to cover have to winning
with the French all the time this is
kind of weird he not an opening where
score squat score well usually but some
nice games against the right kind of
opponent the French is really excellent
it's not bad anyway but there's some
some people really don't don't handle
those close type of position very well
but others are just great at it and he
made some some questionable choices ya
know he's letting the clock run don't ya
what's so quite questionable white
resigns yeah it actually starts I mean
it just blitzed blitzed like no tomorrow
the first couple of moves and here we
already in a position where white is
fighting for equality
he just has given up his most important
piece on d3 but okay he is equal but he
has to be quite circumspect around here
this is already better for black this
Bashevis is getting active and the
queenside is weak this is all on dark
squares so the light squares are weak my
bishop is coming and entering the
position so it is some just a little bit
more comfortable for black yeah should
have eight I want to keep the good piece
yeah and here this this and now the
question a five or ninety five I wasn't
sure a five I wasn't sure about the
CAPTCHA actually probably this is a
nonsensical thing I appreciate bishop if
I miss the most
now that I didn't see
yeah this kind of thing is very strong
okay this also leads to an advantage but
it wasn't this wasn't s convincing but
it is ya fg5 even me to meet my
weaknesses and here this is excellent
for black from a practical point of view
and the way it went down
f3 hand just gave me there's a no no I
think it's this this must be over Russia
page 4
yeah it's winning one one funny line is
if he takes and goes here I have I
thought I have this check yeah it made
it it's a fun line that is so yeah this
was a nice game but tip he was really
helping me a lot
giving up the 9 squared Bishop lend so
on okay thanks for watching